Mario
one sec
all right very good so
hearing me laughing
Mr Mikey Mr Michael
yeah
okay
so
today
you see the time to your yourself so you
can read so
um it's the main topic today is about
the one thing which surrounds the eye at
the moment
and that's height
the question is what are the
consequences of it
is it a danger
yeah
foreign
so it's about time
I
surrounding uh artificial intelligence
and the consequences of it and
if that's a danger
and if it's a danger what can we do
about it
so just some short words or not me I
wanted to just introduced my myself
so yes I did a lot of stuff
but in the positions I'm holding at the
moment are complimenting each other so
I'm just
a few words about it
my day job is Central coordinator for
all things data I machine learning
whatever in general
panorale is one of the biggest insurance
companies uh in the world
company what are my
my main my what is my main purpose there
my main task
mainly it's about strategy
okay
it's about implementing an interesting
part mental Community what are the data
on
and last but not least doing concrete
specific projects this is what we all
want to do
and secondly
I'm co-founder and president of dominant
data science group
so what's that
later on
but my main responsibility again is
strategy there I mean huge fan and
driver for educational purposes because
I think is still in its infancy in in
our field
and for sure I'm managing product
projects like the handbook of data
science and the other book we have just
written again
what a bit later on
so
a few words about generally
yes it's an insurance company you can
read how long it's there and how many
people and so on and to force and it's
one of the biggest but what is the most
interesting to me
there's a huge number of digital cases
there so they have data since not the
Middle Ages but depends
and when when I say that Middle Ages I'm
not entirely kidding because actuaries
which are part of them which are like
Insurance mathematicians they really
have data
for a long long long time and they were
nearly the first ones who have that who
had that
second thing
data science group okay what do I care
about it why is the project so close to
my heart it's a non-profit I think this
is important
and it's
for you
by you so it's community
it's for data scientists why data
scientist what does it mean
I think one of the main things you see
if it's like that
that you can do
that
eliminate BS in a in our field and there
is a lot of [ __ ]
and one of the reasons we did that was
educating about it without all the
marketing
foreign
yes we are a Vibrant Community
in that
I think what is important here is we are
created in Rena that's okay
but with the rule about scope
so Awana is from Austria so they
actually has been there
oh yeah come on that's good
so it's a
a city really in the heart of Europe
really in the middle of it and when it's
open and and inviting others
um and it's it's the strongest
and this is also what our field is about
so this is what I've done yes
before we we Jump Right In now short
primer I will use words like machine
learning AI data science we and we all
have a picture in our head what that
means
and there are different pictures and
none of these pictures are still wrong
but the picture we have in our head are
mostly like that thanks to Catherine for
for actually doing that we all have just
discovered service okay thank you
um
so when we talk about the I get large
part of it is part of data science
because we deeply believe data Sciences
what engulfs
all of these things
and there is one important thing later
where I will talk to you about later on
domain a piece of knowledge
this is actually what
in our opinion
the biggest problem one of the biggest
problems in the field but more of that
later on so
let's Jump Right In
let's start with some figures we'd like
numbers isn't it
so correction here is
does machine learning AI deliver
and you may have heard of that yes it's
gardener they are doing a lot of numbers
and figures
but I think that what it wants to tell
us
that's correct because it basically is
what we are seeing as well
85 percent of the iron machine learning
projects paid to deliver
okay
it's quite impossible
53 percent of projects make different
prototypes to production so this is like
you can say the glass is half empty or
whole food
so it maybe depends on your character if
that's positive or negative you can say
well come on
it's about 85 percent don't deliver
that's a high number
so let's say the majority of it of it
so why is why is that
so that's the question
so
think about the
the questions
you may have asked yourself before an AI
project
or jump right into something and it were
questions like that
to have enough data
choose the right algorithm should I take
two two a or cool B
do we have the right skill sets from our
team or if there isn't a team do I have
the right skill setting because of
something like that
and these are all very questions don't
get me wrong it's really that's just the
basic I mean that's like you should do
that
because it tackles these areas it's
Quality Tool selection algorithm and
steam skills yeah cool and the
associated dangers are all very real you
can have insufficient data
inappropriate tools
non-fitting algorithms and team skills
are
not really there but
the question is now are these the
biggest dangers to our field
and still you remember
a lot of these projects don't deliver so
what's the thing is interesting
so in our opinion
it's a lot of them
it's
hi
thank you
the high surrounding nearly all of
Europeans
okay
and it may be it is like this lion
staring you interface and one wanting to
eat you
Maybe
so
hi
according to Wikipedia is promotion
consisting of exaggerated claims
software marketing
and so don't get me wrong marketing is
it's okay you need it if you're a
company and so on
hype is much more
so
again partner so who who actually knows
that knows this graph the half circle
yeah some so high as in high prison life
cycle these days it seems I think we
have all experienced it
so some technology comes into the fields
let's say deep learning
you can pick whatever you want to
correct
and then it's a sharp release okay up to
the peak of inflated expectations and I
really have to say all these words here
are super cool the trout
disillusionments
the slope of Enlightenment and the total
productivity I think it took quite a lot
of a long time that they got this right
um the whole point here is I think we
we felt it somehow
and
they're going to start going down
is in a lot of
Industries companies
even even countries
what what we've seen
so
let's look at some
examples
which you may have already heard
in this life cycle
singularities near
whatever that is
somehow like
I don't know sometimes it's it's we're
all gonna die or we all kind of live in
Paradise or something like that
then the typical using tool a and you
can now put in either here to
some Quantum sorry
um all our AI projects will succeed
all jobs will be done by machines
and I will definitely
so that's why it's p
because then
I met a lot of people yes that's better
about to come on that's cool for me
and
for sure the last one you may have heard
is this Texas job of the 21st century
well it's from DJ petrol from 2002 I
think in in Harvard Business Review who
has heard of that or read the article
okay I'm getting a little time
so but there is a second part 10 years
after that
however he actually thought about okay
what what what's going on in the field
it's pretty interesting really
it's uttering on the internet
and yes for sure
this was one of the
um
biggest motivations we had to start
doing ideas because the one who doesn't
want to be sexy
we all wanted to say
56 okay
and now some examples of the valley
before the trial of disillusionment
AI is only good for detecting tents or
dogs or whatever your your pet needs to
be
our experts and your heart difficult
then number three the DOT
always achieved by the results always
noise action
okay
the typical Singapore passwords and last
but not least all jobs will be done by
machines and I will lose my
mind so
well
but don't get me wrong
it sounds now a bit like I wanna trash
the field and come out and we are just
producing cool [ __ ] and that's gone but
I mean let's stand up go to the cafe eat
some cakes and save this part of the day
because people over time no no
we made awesome Innovations during the
last years
I mean best example for me is autonomous
drug
I mean you all heard about Elon Musk
that say yeah superdrive whatever and
then people just kidding and killing
their sales by driving into
whatever
but
I think a few
weeks ago there was a relatively smaller
article that level 3 was approved in
Germany I think for mysterious
so that was so who is a bit familiar
with with autonomous driving and what
level 3 means one two few but it
basically means
you can drive from the highway and this
is fully legally a lot with 130 kph
without your hands on the steering wheel
and you don't have to take care you
don't have to listen or you can read a
book or whatever I think it's 15 seconds
that you have to actually regain control
so what you can do is just sit there
read a book and if there's some signal
happening will look okay what's
happening and then you put your hands
back on steering and that's
in my opinion huge achievement but it's
not so sexy it's not like yeah I'm just
jumping and then jump out
no it's not but
this cost of billions
really billions or to achieve that and
it will cost further billions
to actually when go to the next Lab
going now more a bit into technical
things
Transformers
new type
and if you look at gpd3 or
whatever just comes to your mind
okay that's big
or things like like data
where you have them one thing for
multiple purposes that's really cool
I mean it's really a good step forward
so
I want that to happen I don't want much
more colorful things to happen
but how to do that
if realities hype cycle and everybody is
either thinking we will all be Gods
singularities near or some sentient
being will come and rescue us or we will
all die pretty basically because before
this is fueled by fear that's why I said
in my talk before
heightened for you this is human fear
people are refreshed
oh
basically that or whatever
the goal is here to smooth this curve
okay
because
basically nobody is that
needs that in sense of doing death
because most of the people I know just
want to do good projects and yes earn
money and maybe famous a bit that's okay
but we need that to
because what is the biggest Danger a lot
of people in the field I'm talking with
Alex
don't care I mean that's a natural
Evolution okay we are maybe here yeah it
will get a bit worse okay but then there
will be the slope of enlightenment
and then we can live on Happily Ever
After
no
this is not natural
because
there was something called an AI winter
before who has heard about that
again if you so for the rest that was
please correct me if I'm wrong
starting 90s roughly middle of the
series
uh when basically the first pipe went
down
and stayed down
so like not like that but it was like
that me
so yes research was going on talking to
one of them the thing wasn't hard enough
since 2008
um by Google because it just did oh yeah
we are there now
they're doing a lot of research but
people are going to nibs circumference
and
just being on their own my life which is
somehow good
so
it's mostly curve
this is actually what's important
because otherwise
I really fear that the next Dr winter
can
it's a really
possible Danger
so
how to do that
I mean sounds like
it's an official Gardener is doing that
and he's moves the curve okay
so
unfortunately there is not
one measure to do it all one fix one
magical fix was like this magically eye
dust we have to sprinkle on a lot of
projects and say that that's it icons
it's actually a bit more
not complicated but maybe it won't work
maybe it's just boring but let's see
people
data and Technology
is what we all like speak about
and process
which is often
velocity overlooked
so nice
start with the first
people
and I think it's
one of the most important ones or no it
is the most important
let's talk about teams
because they decide
hey hi whatever you want to call it
is a team sport
it's people working together and you
will see what I mean instead
it's and you see it in this picture it's
a different skill set which people
possess and they have to work together
very very closely intimate
so what is this skill set
these teams should have
the content time
it consists of first hard skills
this is pretty straightforward you heard
some of them data engineering I want to
explain here more and more data engine
is coming and talking about the best
wages at the moment
data analytics are more harm modeling
this is what often is perceived
the state assigns at the moment
because data scientists are just doing
Works isn't it
storytelling communication
vastly under reality
what does it help to have the best model
the best algorithm
if you can't communicate it if you can't
visualize it
again these are roles all things I've
read so often
and I've seen
in reality not so
and connected with this is this
yes you need to visualize
you need to visualize for your customers
and your customers can be internal can
be external
whatever
and last but really not least
domain knowledge you have to know in
which industry you are in
what is going on there
why
so if you're working for finance
and in risk management and you don't
know how the loan is processed and
you're working with the data generated
by this process
have fun
because you will do something and then
there will be a meeting and this meeting
will end in
a lot of question marks
and I said last but not least but I
forgot one which is
getting more and more attention now
and I think that's really good
when I when I write your devops I mean
AI helps envelopes however you want to
you want to term it at the moment
because
in my experience
when what you have seen the 85 which
don't deliver
when do they don't deliver a lot of
these projects don't deliver
near the end so yes there's data and
there is some and there is some models
and there are some results and the
results are presented and some people
are saying oh that's cool
then it's forgot
just
yeah
there's a drawer put it in close the
door that is added since so putting it
into production
this is one of the biggest
sing situation moments one of the
biggest notes so our skills
quite a lot
but when I write hard skills yes there
are also soft skills
and yes they are needed
and
after a long years of working with teams
creating teams leading teams in in
different companies
in different Industries
in my opinion it boils down
two days
these teams
should possess these four skills
and first one
sounds quite easy you should be humble
and respect your co-workers
you have to have an open mind
that maybe there is another way a simple
way of doing stuff
because there is maybe an expert well
actually did that for 20 years and did
some cool stuff
foreign
but then something happens
I don't know
something doesn't work out data is cheap
as always
um there's no
so you have to be resilient
to actually say okay first thing first
way it didn't work so let's try
something let's try something else so
you have to be
flexible
so not not just seeing your tongue
so this helps for that
but again if you have these
and you'll still think I don't care I'm
humble I'm flexible I'm a sillier but
I'm not here
they hungry
to change something to transform
something because what we do at the
moment in companies is transforming them
we are threatening a lot of people often
do you remember the fear
and then because some people can't
direct this height
okay now
we will change the whole company get rid
of 80 of the people and please love me
for that
what happened
so
why a lot of skills that's why I say
this didn't have a team sport
so how do I how do I acquire these
well
you're sitting in a university so
obviously that's one of the ways there's
YouTube there is
all kind of stuff so it can have a
lecture about it
won't do it I will just concentrate on
one
leave your bubble
because we are all living in one
we're living in a bubble where hype is
now Rising
and if it's if you're in the company if
it's big if it's small
it doesn't matter
there will be other people at this
you're a one-man company okay
so then maybe look yourself in the
mirror maybe the times
inside your company
I think start with this
become a data or a higher investor
hummingbirds we have a good example here
today question is doing that maybe just
wave Kashmir is doing that in your
company e-commerce so if you have
questions how that works out
here hands on
and through that build an internal
Community there will be other people who
are working with data there maybe they
don't have this formal education or
whatever
doesn't matter
bring to me they've lost experience they
know the data
who
and if that
and if that all you have achieved if
that's all
it's cool
then you may start in your phone away
in a lot of bigger companies I've worked
with they are starting debt they are
holding it Academy or shop or whatever
you want to know okay you really want to
climb it
but the purpose is to educate the rest
of the workforce
which is good they can have some YouTube
videos that's cool
but actually the other upside is
if you educate people you talk to them
and you get a lot of business and use
cases
definitely so people are talking about
their own problems like yeah that's cool
what you're doing and three years ago I
did that and
you get a picture
so that's inside your company
in real life well
China Community black Data Center
because it's the best way to keep
sinning it's the best way to counteract
the hype with people telling you
the plain truth
like I think that didn't work out that
[ __ ] that's a to worry okay no and
so on and so forth so people who don't
support dad
or
but you already did the first step go to
conferences like painting them
because it's actually leaving your
bubble your company or whatever talk
with some people openly
because otherwise you're just yeah
pushing some
um
let's say some sentences you already
heard before like similarities in you
Maybe
okay so that's basically about people
let's have a short
talk about data and Technology
I couldn't filled the entire talk the
entire day and the next
half year about that so because
it's lost and one of the best
talks I hear during the last
years was yesterday from Assad don't
know who who has been there I should it
was cool so enthusiastic so really deep
into it so
Russia recommends to to watch it if you
haven't been there
so
that's two of us do I want to just
concentrate
on some principles
which you can remember afterwards
so let's start with the question
um sometimes you you go into a new field
or a new company or whatever and
some things are existing there like I
don't know
some
data pipeline somehow or some algorithm
running somewhere or whatever
and then
um this company says now we want to do
the big bang now we wanted to build a
data platform
and then people and yes I also did that
and to end up at something like that
though
and it's cool
I mean
um the guy actually writing about this
it happened to know what he's talking
about and people are taking that and
then we have to implement it on the top
okay
but the question is
does it fit your your need does one size
fits all should we do that in every
company in every
country
or
what should you think about first
think about what you need
not not download some blueprint from
from the internet
think about what you need
and here I I borrow from from our
handbook and from short term in in
particular who who did that and I really
like this this pyramid
I really like it
who knows
um Master loves pyramid of needs okay
that's the requirement of data needs
and it's the same
start basic
take the collection if you don't have
data collect something
yeah I'm very surprising
cleans it integrate it
for very few need and if you have done
that
you can start humble and see do some
piece of intelligence some exploratory
data analysis whatever
then you you can think about that called
the eye machine learning
whatever the like
but most start here
so because you pick upside down because
they are discovering then
we don't have that much data
and
so think about your needs first
and if you have the needs that's cool
by the way
Terra Stills and basic requirements for
platform really
simple stuff
should be reliable
and I've only got five minutes time
it should be maintainable
I should be scalable and
capability it's a good virtue
because
all maze remember this principles
yeah
you ain't gonna need it
if you think about that's a cool
technology to do maybe I need it no
you ain't gonna need it
and second keep it simple to rest you
can make
so principles or requirements needs
this is important when or when you think
about the data platform or technology or
whatever you're doing okay last pillar
process
I actually be a bit faster now but maybe
I can
I have a few extra minutes because I
started late
it's a process I talked about Big Bang
and especially the larger companies I've
worked for are rolling for the Big Bang
because we need plans we wanted two
plans for a long time and after we are
planning for one year we are
implementing it and after three years we
don't remember why we did it but it's
cool
so are there alternatives to this is The
Rock
so one of the things
we should start with
I like those projects
yes it's just normal projects but you
it's good to call them write this
project and I counted it
what should they do
yeah the show should they should show
the capabilities that's pretty
straightforward but again keep it simple
so best thing is
I want to do a neural network and we
just talked talked yesterday
um maybe it's just a logistic regression
which is doing the chop but again you
show some added value
it shows the pitfalls during the
projects again
playing a bit I'm not saying start
immediately kind of it
but not are don't wait until all the
pitfalls are
yeah
and that is because you will wait
forever
in a bigger company it should be in the
departmental
okay leave your bubble
talk with other people I.T business
units control the marketing go out there
and it should have a sizeable potential
impact size people so not I I will
rescue the company but it should be
sense for this type of company you're in
so you have a project
so what is the process
have good
and I just borrowed from Casey kosher
coffee Chief decision scientist Google I
really recommend our talks blogs
whatever whoa who
has heard of her Casey
I'm not that much you really listen to
her
one of her main points and she she is
doing
vastly much good points is
where to start
often company starts here what data do
we have
it's okay but most of the companies I
worked for and I know don't care about
that
to care about that
they care about
dude I have this analogy what do we want
to eat
and not do or if you have tomatoes
so they care about oh I like pizza I
like pretty pictures I like beehive
products
dishes
so start there
not to start with algorithms so like do
we need the flames roar or an oven
I don't know
what do you want to serve
if you want to serve
pizza then a flamethrower might not be
the best
maybe it works out for you
that might be the best okay
and models recipe for pizza or
whatever you'd like from us
so start with the dishes
and ask them what what are you going to
eat
so to be more specific here I will just
skip over that a bit
yes EI project should start with the
business decision maker
you should ask him or her what do you
want to eat
a good way of doing that he starts with
a simple
document answering some simple questions
what does it mean to do your task
correctly what are you doing fraud
selling something I don't know
which mistakes which which mistakes are
worse than other mistakes what
it's okay and what is really bad
and how do you grade that how do you
give that a score if you're doing good
work bad work whatever
and if this is hard like again
thank you Kate
however you want me and internet
evangelists they can start indicating me
whatever
so
that that was a wild ride through the
through the three pillars now let's
I want to show you what eats most of my
day time
during my day job
and
if I'm doing what I'm talking about or
just preaching to you
and doing something completely different
so
generally actually has this type of
organization it's decentralized it has a
strong Community I care about that
and it has a strong interdepartmental
inter-departmental that was always the
hardest word to be honest
cooperation on specific project so
quite shortly so the experts are sitting
here in CRM in operations and claims
the the AI coordination you see here and
it is pretty straightforward
so
when you have this type of organization
you still need help
ing data science lab Center of
Excellence whatever but what they are
doing
is this the righteous projects I just
talked about
because yes
um again it's important and
I would recommend doing it in an actual
way so a lot of people here may ask may
say may is there another way yes there
are but HR is fitting infrastructure
will just skip over that one important
Point here
there are still a lot of Industries out
there but be flexible be pragmatic Jose
Cloud that's nice
but
hard
we don't want that and so on and so
forth so keep in mind there is still a
lot of companies out there to say can
you do that on premise can you do that
on our servers
so that's that's important and let's see
if you have question marks in the
interfaces here so
it's basically like no it's not
one-sided one side speaks all for the
database form you have to deal with it
and and ask them do you have a server
oh what is the server
important
so just geography what are we doing
at the moment
at the moment we are our main project is
about fruit it's a huge business case in
in insurance so since decades so people
are doing that for a long long time
speaking about speaking to the business
experts
what is fraud
anyways leading action which was
something the benefit for them or others
so if you
bump into into a car
and you are insured
well there are possible ways of
being fraudulent there it never come
into the account
you bumped into it but you said my whole
car was destroyed
okay
so what are we doing
um most important thing is more or less
dead
because what you do there you have a
vast
a bus community of experts and you have
to support them more or less
what are the tools just getting a bit
technical
at the moment the whole life change and
yes you will deal with a lot of rule and
change if you are anything some experts
say this is the group
supervised and support so basically
everything you dream about and that's
cool and you can do a lot of stuff here
with all types of data
what we are focusing on at the moment is
this because our data quantity and
quality seems good enough we are roughly
two months in so hopefully during the
next part data I can present you some
very cool results what we did with this
very very big numbers we have saved
let's see
I gave you examples
what are examples for for fraud
scope of this project and this is also
important about the sizable potential
impact
power home and health business
everything
which is cool but also quite
challenging
and I won't lie to you for sure there
are challenges and threats to this
project as always
so people you have to really talk to
people what is this code what is most
important all the time
flooded Wonder
the expectations are too high
speaking about hype
because there are people from from
business
saying ah come on I read in
pick the pick a newspaper that you will
save the world and you know we won't
have to go
and for sure collaboration falls short
because yes you can do all all you want
sometimes it doesn't work out but it's
something you have to be aware of
so
if that was not enough
and you're still interested in all these
topics we actually wrote a book about
that
when a data science group one of the one
of the biggest projects for the last one
and a half years if you plan on writing
a book it takes time
serious amounts of time
so
just be warned because we were maybe
there
um
and we very bit
Mega romantic maybe and said let's write
a book about everything
I think it's somehow we're about
not just by having certain authors who
are part of this
and this is important because you see
it's only possible by the power of a
very diverse community
there is no one guy who can do it at
least I haven't met him
maybe he's in the audience or girl sorry
um so please please speak to me
afterwards I would really like to meet
you
so I won't recite that thanks to
unfortunately Armin isn't here thanks to
arm and
writing the forward here
so there's also a connection to here to
the AOA
and this is the last slide I promise but
there are four key takeaways
normally this is this Library I'll tell
you go on and everything is cool and we
will save the world
Maybe
but to do that first
there's an old song from Public Enemy
don't believe the hype
because it's the first thing you can do
just don't fall for it don't believe it
second
concentrate on serving awesome dishes
so basically you want to surreptitious
you want to do predictions AI products
be pragmatic
and handsome
don't overseeing don't focus on on some
tool or some method because you know it
or it sounds cool or whatever
might last but not least join
communities
because they are the best way of keeping
you sane and I'm not seeing my nana
no I'm not seeing her
she she started something similar here
in
policy so you can make the connection
Thursday the point of many are very
similar to data science group in in
Vienna connect third row to the left
Monica sorry
and that's basically it thank you for
for having the time and patience
and I'm looking for questions thank you
[Applause]
which other countries are the members of
Vienna data science group
in which other countries are the members
of Vienna data science group
we are awareness in the middle of Europe
so there's always this strong crime
especially from Central and Eastern
Europe to to concentrate there so
Hungary Czech Republic but also Germany
I mean that's quite near Clear we also
have a member in Paris
so quite disbursed around Central and
Eastern Europe
yes I'm for sure Armenia
um that was so that was so clear that it
was even giveness sorry it was so that's
7 30. you talked about hype cycle and
that a lot of people and companies fall
for the highest cycle
so in your experience here a lot of
people who work in companies and there's
others what are the typical science
someone or some company
failed for a hype sex in your opinion
thanks for that
well well
first time I I talked about a bit
um
they are concentrating on mostly on
Technologies so we're just saying we
need especially that because then we
will be complying with CI and then you
feel it a bit when you talk to I don't
know managers efficiently because they
are
where I have to have business cases with
a very large dollar values behind it
very very large and they say
it's cool that you think that but
maybe that's a bit too optimistic
and there's maybe last couple of days
they are just citing
one or two articles
they read maybe the day before
so
various times and different parts
so yeah this is the answer to the
question yeah
muscles can come with the coffee right
as well questions can come through yeah
come on afterwards
thank you for this representation uh
what do you think about next five years
uh development industry in terms of uh
there is some Advocates updates and the
platform improvements like for example
yesterday we had several good reports
about Auto nail development um
development Technologies
so this is supposed to change uh
the shield and the processes in Industry
I think because it just need uh don't
need to waste your time in data
processing to be at the Baseline results
for different results so you're talking
about automl and wireless it's one of
the examples of some features let's
let's take out the mail so let's say
that really works out
in the whole process of doing of doing
what we're doing building data products
it's one step so
maybe it works out and I know people on
both sides who are saying this this is
full internet real life I've been 100
that we don't need mothers anymore
there are others
who say come on that's just for
scriptcase
but even if it works
it's just one part
and
when you have seen this apartment of
need state of needs
what takes the longest time in your
projects
the longest time in your project is
digging through the data typically
and I haven't seen
somebody really automatizing that
for
many use cases
so
technology wise this this may be one of
one of the things but again
I have the feeling that
um
technology
will be one important part
but it may not be the deciding part if
we enter another winter
because use cases
are failing off not because of
Technology
so it may not be
in a lot of use cases that is citing
sector
I'm not saying it's not important don't
get me wrong
it is important
so you have to do that right
but often projects are failing just
because of other reasons does it answer
the question yeah okay
[Applause]